today's program is a collaboration with
the pointer journalism fellowship here
at Yale and the Frankie program
Christopher is brought to us by the
generous gifts of rich and Barbara
Frankie today's talk is by David Dobbs
David writes features and essays for the
New York Times national Geographics late
the Atlantic nature and other
publications is now working on his fifth
book called The Orchid and the dandelion
about how genes and culture generate
temperament and behavior in humans the
book expands on ideas explored in a
much-discussed feature article in the
Atlantic The Orchid children and the
social life of genes recently published
5 Pacific Standard dave is the author of
four previous books including my
mother's lover a number one best-selling
kindle work and he comes to us from
montpelier
thank you very very much for coming and
for having me special thanks to the
Frankie's for helping to sponsor this
talk along with the pointer program
received the an invitation via Carl
Zimmer it's a small world turns out Rick
a good friend of his a good friend of
mine up in Montpelier the birder Brian
Pfeiffer and I was not born into the
Yale family I did not go to Yale I went
to Oberlin but I married into the Yale
family I married a Yalie and who's not
here today but so therefore I think I
can take a family pleasure in announcing
well I'm not announcing a news but in
sharing some good news from the Yale
family and that attending the talk today
is someone who's twice scanned my brain
told me I had a hole in it twice and
this is joy Hirsch who sits in the front
row and her big news for the week is
that her husband Jim Rothman won the
nobel prize in medicine two days ago I'm
really honored that she's here with us
so so very happy news in a fine
environment to consider how genes and
environment shape behavior and how to
write about this very slippery new field
in a way this talk is about two or three
fields in a state of crisis confusion
regrouping big transitions one of them
is genetics which is I think fair to say
still regrouping trying to find a steady
stance when in the aftermath of the
Human Genome Project which showed us
that it you know the line from switch to
light bulb was not going to be nearly as
distinct as we had hoped pre Genome
Project another area is the study of
behavior in general which is kind of odd
as a haunted history a lot of crackpot
ideas a lot of really good ideas some
ideas with a
lot of good evidence under them other
ideas with only a little bit of good
evidence under them other ideas with
none at all underneath them and and then
what happens if you're stupid enough to
write about behavioral genetics at this
time when all these fields are in crisis
because the third field that is in
disruption right now and I think needs
to think is hard about reshaping itself
as the others is writing about behavior
which most of my writing is about how
behavior is shaped and about ideas about
behavior is shaped so first I'm going to
describe an idea i ran across four years
ago when well i'll walk you through it
now this is the basis of this book that
I'm writing the orchid in the dandelion
and the basic idea here I ran into it at
a at a conference for years ago oh yeah
four years ago and in two talks one by a
child psychologist who described
dynamics and children that I'll
elaborate on in a minute fitting this
hypothesis and then by a primatologist
who described some of the same things
kind of converging lines of evidence you
like to see and the idea behind this
hypothesis which one of the researchers
coined the orchid and align hypothesis
is that humanity is distinguished by a
range of response to our environments to
our experience where at one end of this
spectrum are what Swedish distinction of
vernacular distinction calls dandelion
children these are children and people
who no matter what their luck in life is
or what their experiences what kind of
soil they grow up in they're going to
turn out about the same it's not to say
they'll be unremarkable but what they
were meant to be so to speak they'll be
there not relatively unruffled these are
people who would say everything rolls
off
Beck's right so this is at one end of a
spectrum at the other our orchid
children who are highly sensitive to
their environments and whereas the
dandelion will you know do about the
same if they're in a sidewalk crack or a
garden or a greenhouse the orchid will
be highly sensitive to its its
environment experience and will wilt in
the sidewalk crack do okay in the garden
and the greenhouse its own type of green
hunt will make grow into something
extraordinary so a range of sensitivity
and these are types at either end of a
spectrum of course this this idea was
the phrase was coined by this researcher
Thomas boys whose at Berkeley now was at
Berkeley and then you b.c british
columbia and then back to berkeley a a
pediatrician who got into studies of
children and saw that kids that were
very reactive to their home environments
were also very reactive in various
physiological measures and also showed
in their health outcomes they're more
likely to have worse asthma attacks than
someone without this sort of sensitivity
and another researcher Jay belsky who's
on the right there with a colleague of
his and I don't know who the infant is
it's not theirs I'm assuming because
they know they just work together but
Jay Bielski came at this idea from a
more evolutionary standpoint he wondered
why he had seen in the literature and in
in various research he did that the same
kind of range and what struck him the
first clue was that the kids who were
the most temperamental by child
development measures of temperament
seemed to be the ones that got the most
out of better the better childhood
interventions it gets to see most in
trouble because things were bad at home
gained the most it seemed to him from
you know successful interventions so
they both developed this over
over the years and this is the basic
outline of this this idea and this is in
a sense so it was first a statement
about temperament and then it became
tied to a body of genetic research that
came out of psychiatric genetics that
looked at a handful of genes that in
many studies not all that looked into it
but in many studies were associated with
mood and behavioral disorders like
depression in a serotonin transporter
gene there was a variant of it if you
had it you were more prone to depression
there was a variant of a dopamine
processing Jane drd4 there was
associated with hyperactivity antisocial
behavior things like that and a handful
of other genes that were considered risk
genes for these mood and behavioral
disorders and this that risk gene
hypothesis was became the dominant one
between its emergence in the mid to late
1990s and about well through the 2000s
and what it looked at was here's the the
negative environment and the you know
the the bad gene the wrist gene at the
bottom and you got this kind of curve
the worse the environment the worse the
outcome if you had that gene so the gene
didn't make you more itself didn't
matter unless you had a bad environment
then you had a higher statistical risk
of suffering whatever the problem was
where's the people with the other
variant of whatever gene was in question
ran more along a line like this this is
kind of the model of it it doesn't
represent any direct data so this is the
risk gene model it's it's focused on
dysfunction and bad in bad environment
because they're their psychiatrist so
what makes people sick now the orchid
dandelion hypothesis is different as I
described it right it's not about just a
downside there's an upside to these same
genes it recasts things like this okay
it's a matter of are you more
susceptible to your environment more
responsive more sensitive to it
and this dotted line describes the data
that it would posit and if you look in
the literature from the psychiatric risk
gene literature again and again and
again what you see are these crossed
sticks the non risk gene version running
more or less flat in response I mean
everyone's subject to environment these
are relative measures and the people
with the risk gene do worse and bad
environments and better in good
environments can everyone hear me okay
even when i leave the mic okay it's
usually not a problem so there's a
handful of Jesus drd4 with two things in
one called maoa a serotonin transporter
gene a few others we won't go into the
weeds with which ones but this is the
model okay and it became rapidly became
very influential in in child development
in Psychological circles and it has some
implications you can see right away if
you because these are tied to trades I
mean you can think of the genes are sort
of proxies for traits in a sense and the
trains what's what's very clear and
pretty much incontrovertible from the
literature is that humans do have a
range of sensitivity some people are
more sensitive in experience than others
in all kinds of measures eegees blood
cortisol measures of behavior and that
that is a neurobiological sensitivity
range of sensitivity of the varies so
the extra layer here that the part
that's not quite as firmly established
it's not encounter over table is the
genetic add-on okay that it's tied to
this handful of James where is this
seemingly native variation in timmerman
but what you get when you look at these
studies again and again and again is
what I call just for myself this this
crossed stick graphs and I'm not going
to go through and tell you you know read
every slide to tell you what but these
are different measures of genes against
environment and again and again you'll
see the flatter graph line is associated
with the non risk gene and the steeper
slope this is serotonin transporter gene
if you have SS like I do this is your
world right by the theory and you see it
again and again in all these different
genes and measures so this is I think a
DRD no it's it's the serotonin
transporter gene again here's one
associated with yes maoa and violence
and antisocial behavior later here's
another one you can read it better than
I came another MOA a bunch of these and
again and again you see the same sort of
cross stick this one's a little more
confused because there's four measures
it's this was significant as an
experimental forecast where they
actually tested the environment it
tested this theory with hypothesis with
a change in the children's environment
and saw that the kids with the risk
genes the plasticity gene sensitivity
jeans orchid jeans whatever you want to
call them they did indeed benefit more
from the intervention that helped
families know how to deal with very very
difficult children the most difficult
children in the country of the
Netherlands so along with this Oh what
go is another layer that was first
pushed by Belski which is okay there's a
bunch of these genes a handful you know
610 everybody has their shortlist but
there's five that show up five or six it
show up consistently in the literature
and that the more of these you have the
more plastic you'll be the more
responsive to your environment so this
would be your prediction right this is
what the grass would look like from that
the prediction of that multigenic
adjective hypothesis and what he did a
couple of studies that there need to be
more they can always be bigger these are
several hundred people that's kind of a
lot a whole genome person would tell you
huh you're not getting started so here's
the result from one of the first ones
that did jay Bielski compile and oh
there was another one that I guess I cut
out but they're so there's two or three
of these studies now that that answer
this question that support the idea that
as these as you have more of these are
more sensitive in response to your
environment they also offer an answer
I'm not saying it's the
the answer but they offer an answer to a
big problem that has bedeviled the
candidate gene risk gene hypothesis
which is that a lot of times people will
do one of these Canada gene hypothesis
experiments they'll cast a change or a
state of environment against gene
variant and they won't find an effect
this this cross stick both sticks will
be the same now that could be because
the whole candidate gene hypothesis is
buncombe or what else could it be for
this is one possible explanation because
you see here that if with zero or one of
these alleles there's no effect in this
one study and in another one like it but
when you have to that's when you get the
cross stick so in all those other
studies which were in single genes the
ones that showed up were the ones that
probably perhaps had two or more of
these alleles to make them more
responsive and kind of show up on on the
graph as it were ah ah so there's a
bunch of other evidence that it folds
into this this is the this is the
results of an experiment that the Leiden
team in leiden netherlands a very very
lovely town did that found that the kids
that were most at risk and we're doing
the worst and had this risk gene their
bad behaviors drop the steepest from the
intervention and in a lasting way the
follow-up was if i remember about a year
after the end of the intervention so
it's stuck with those families now one
possible confound is well the mothers
maybe they had a genetic makeup they
didn't they haven't filtered that out
yet so this is the idea that there's a
handful of genes formally seen as risk
genes or they're getting recast here our
sensitivity genes it's not about risk
it's about possibility it's not about
vulnerability it's about responsiveness
and you can see this can change your
view of the traits that and perhaps the
genes that make one vulnerable to stress
trauma that make you more likely to dive
when thing
things are really going badly if if you
think that those only as weaknesses
you're in one sort of state of self
conception what I mean that in a dirty
way but if you if you see it as know
there's an upside here too because if
this is really about responds to
environment I will respond better to the
good things in an environment and you
might actually feel a heightened sense
of agency more control over your life
and your mood under the eye under the
premise that you can change our
environment and you will you will rise
with those efforts all right so this is
just one implication there are others
about evolution some of these there's no
iphone some of these theorists think and
some anthropologists think that perhaps
this wide range of responds to
environment and the variation in range
in response to environment that these
genes confer on humanity may be part of
the reason along with many other assets
that were so successful as a species not
so good at governing but you know we've
covered the planet in a way that is
unusual and this is ideas given some
support in some eyes by the fact that
many of these polymorphisms these genes
that took on a second form the
plasticity gene these plasticity
variants emerged in Homo sapiens most of
them in the last forty to eighty
thousand years which corresponds to the
time period in which we have colonized
the entire planet you know moved out of
Africa and did whatever we did to the
Neanderthals and took over the world now
there's that's one line of evidence or
several there's also physiological lines
of evidence about the power and that
serotonin in particular plays roles in
social in response to social environment
when grasshoppers become locusts for
instance it's the
signal that drives that change is
crowding and food but it's mainly a
crowding thing it's a it's a social
change in social environment as it were
and that creates a sharp spike in
serotonin that fades but that's what
drives this tremendous change that
changes a grasshopper into a locust it's
the same animal but you know I used to
actually think there were different
animals you could be forgiven because
they look different that you no one has
longer lens and the locust has a bigger
head to contain a rapid growth of the
brain presumably to negotiate this
complicated high-stakes world you're
suddenly in as a locus where like if you
go too slow the guy behind you each you
stuff like that so and there's another
line of evidence that's quite compelling
and that is the work of a guy named
Stephen sue me how many familiar with
Stephen Sumi's work how many people have
heard of Harry Harlow okay and that line
of work Stephen sue me was one of Harry
Harlow's students and protégées and the
work he does at NIH not this week
carries fourth us harlows essential
investigation into what the the creation
of temperament right this is a Harlow
it's a very stark sometimes upsetting
experiments looked at how does early
experience shape temperament what makes
a really nervous monkey what makes a
successful monkey and sumi has continued
this line of work using a paradigm that
that Harlow developed originally
actually where some monkeys are raised
just either early weeks and months just
together with other monkey's their age
here this is the pier raised group and
then other monkeys who are just raised
as usual by their moms and in rhesus
live in matriarchal matrilineal groups
right little kind of troops that are
made up of families organized around
maître line so mother grandmother and so
on the young grow up at about a
wonderful ratio compared to humans so a
four-year-old rhesus is roughly
equivalent to a 16 year old
tumon got it the moms give birth every
year usually to one child daughters stay
with that group and start mating at
about four years for 26 years sons leave
at about four years live a while in
all-male gangs and then try to work
their way into a new troop this is a
really high risk time for the young
males as I'll explain in a minute so
anyway the pyramid monkeys they're
nervous little animals and when they
after a few months they join the larger
group they remain nervous their social
skills are poor they bite they they
don't know how to respond to signal's
they did they miss read them and they
don't integrate very well into the very
hierarchical complicated social system
that is rhesus monkey life whereas the
other monkey's the mother raised you
know almost by definition are normal
most of them do well and they learn how
to fit in and create alliances through
grooming and contributing to this this
family based troop and their valued and
allowed to be around a little longer if
they're males and the males those males
tend to be more successful working their
way into new families because half in
that year where they're all in on their
own half the male's die because they get
killed in fights with in their own group
or with other young male gangs or when
they try to get into a new family group
they go amiss or choose poorly and
they're killed in that transition or
they're shunned by their social they're
little male gang and tend to be on the
periphery and they get eaten by
something you don't want to be alone if
you're a rhesus monkey any more than you
do as human so those were the norms from
those two things but sue me was seeing
early on way back that about twenty
percent of the mother raised bookies
turn out not so great about half of them
more neurotic monkey sort of like the
pier raised and about another half were
bullies poor social schools let skills
like some of the pier
so they got in fights they shouldn't got
in they failed to take cues from older
monkeys so they got beat up and when
they went out to join these these
all-male gangs they were often shunned
and didn't make it some some of them
took too much risk jumping in trees
literally and would fall to their deaths
so when about a decade ago sumi could
get ahold of genotyping you know it got
cheap enough and quick enough to the gym
title on these monkeys he found lo and
behold you see this coming that these
monkeys that seem more sensitive to the
mothers environment the mother raised
monkeys that were part of that twenty
percent that they tended to be to carry
the the short version of serotonin
transporter gene which this monkey has
and almost no other primate has other
than humans so and it was just they just
simply had a bigger reaction if they had
an erotic clingy mother they tended or a
harsh mother or neglectful mother they
tended to have trouble and if they had a
competent mother they did actually
better than most of the other monkeys so
extremely interesting line of work that
folds in when he looked around he
started asking his friends to in the
primatology community to to do to type
their monkeys and there's hardly any
other primates with even the serotonin
and there's one or two other than us and
there's where's the rhesus have several
of these polymorphisms of you know
sensitivity genes many other primates
seem to have that have been genotyped
enough to know have multiple of view so
this increases his faith in this idea so
that is this really very powerful idea
that i ran across at this conference for
years ago and how should one right about
this okay this is this is a very
powerful idea people who encounter it i
mean i got a lot of emails from people
when this thing i wrote an article in
the atlantic as richard noted I've never
gotten any kind of response close to the
response
publish see this thing there I got tons
of email asking people asking me how
could they get Jenna typed and this this
resonated you know described her their
sister perfectly or their mom or
themselves or their kids and you know I
got they would say they're ki well i got
dandelion aired I got an orchid you this
is the how this works so how to write
about this well you know one option
which was the is is is do it as fast as
you can and simplify this problem this
idea and overplay its security in the
scientific world and make it the thing
that explains everything right now
because there's a really
well-established genre right this is
much of pop behavioral writing it's a
whole genre of books that I call drawing
partly on the title of one which is
called how we decide that I call how we
behave books and they purport to explain
how we behave now this is a very
interesting thing to study and it's
important thing to understand as best
you can in life because you know it's
important to understand how other people
game but to pretend that science has
figured this out with deep authority so
that you can write a book that's
essentially a cookbook or a self health
book is misguided will be kind and you
know you're seeing this right now I
don't know if you've been reading the
reviews of Malcolm Gladwell's latest
book but there are critics who feel that
he does this to extreme a degree
Christopher shibori orsha Brissac
psychologist wrote a devastating review
of lit Gladwell's latest book in The
Wall Street Journal he said he excels at
cherry-picking week science to tell just
so stories that's a close paraphrase and
so he had then posted his own blog site
there was even more damning and as he
points out and as you could hear
Gladwell's defense here is that he's
using these studies to augment his
storytelling and as shibori and many
others have pointed out well he's not
augment
stories with a science he's this is the
foundation of his storytelling and if
that's the case I think you know you
need to be careful and the accusations
on quite well said he's not careful so
the atlantic's tana he seek oh it's a
wonderful writer he it was fun pondering
the downfall of another writer in this
genre Jonah lair who fell because of
fraud he he fabricated quotes including
one by Bob Dylan which was the thing
that brought him down and so coach said
we now live in a world where
counterintuitive bullshitting is
valorized where the pose of argument is
more important than the actual pursuit
of truth we're clever answers take
presidents or precedence over profound
questions we have no patience for
mystery we want the deciphering of gods
we want Oracle's and I want them right
now I think he's spot on here but if you
ride in this world and you there's just
tremendous pressure on riders to fit
this model because it sells so what's
wrong with doing that well I've offered
some offerings from others I have my own
problems I think it ignores among other
things the extreme the chaos in genetics
the tremendous uncertainty in genetics
and the immaturity I mean I don't mean
that in a bad way but the immaturity of
neuroscience it's a very young field I
was the neuroscience meeting two years
ago I was at a table was about ten
neuroscientist there I thought oh I'll
do a quick poll and I said if zero is
complete ignorance we don't even know
where the brain is and 100 is like
perfect you know working knowledge of it
so that we can answer any question about
how it works where is neuroscience right
now all the answers almost all but one
we're in the single digits 689 this is
from neuro scientists this is our civics
these are neuroscientist one person said
11
um and this is where it is yet we take
these findings and we say oh we figured
out how we do this how we behave we got
the answer and I can tell you how to run
your business based on it so we need to
quit treating these these are puzzles
these are mysteries and we need to quit
treating them as settle pictures because
it's the science it just is not that
neat and so um this has given me pause
as I've worked on this book and dug in
and talk to people are trying to figure
out how do you write about this stuff
and I think it can help to to think
about genre right if they're offering
cookbooks and how-to books and self-help
books maybe we need to think of it'll go
to different part of the bookstore when
we write and read these books may be
more proper genres are ah detective
stories or mysteries now look for
instance at a book that's not about
behavior of science but it shows some of
the things there's no reason you can't
do this about behavioral science and
that is I'm going all li today that is
david quammen spill over this is a book
about zoonosis diseases that animals
that move from the animal spillover as
they say from the animal kingdom into
humanity and a lot of the scary diseases
we're worried about lately are part of
these diseases they spill over there
they've come SARS flu and so on he
writes this lovely book about the
scientists are trying to hunt these
things down now what is this this is a
this is a whodunit this is a what done
it what are these things that are
killing us how do they get here how did
they show up where do they how do they
get from that cave to this little girl
they kill and it generates this
delicious g-power because he doesn't try
with every chapter or anecdote to
resolve a mish
tree or question he tries to explore he
watches people explored he shows him
explored he embraces constantly the
mystery of where these things came from
and how they spill and spread through
humanity so he's shedding light but he's
not pretending that we're seeing
everything he's shedding light and
showing us that when you when you show
light you do find some things out but
you also find more real dark holes and
caves and corners where we don't know
what the hell is going on or to use
another metaphor he's he's sort of
embracing the what I think of as the
island model of knowledge the growing
island so as we learn more the island of
what we know expands but the border
between what we know and what we don't
know gets ever bigger this is how
science works right this is what
happened with the genome big time like
the island quintupled in size and
somebody do the math for me I was an
English major whatever that does due to
the perimeter of the island that's what
it did so how can you you I think it
helps to think about different genres
and to think about what you can add
where how do you work that mystery and
what else do you get when you admit the
mystery that you don't get if you deny
the mystery well one thing you get is um
and this this is a little I get a bonus
having joy come because if you think of
this in terms of winning the Nobel Prize
it really Stroh's us into relief is this
frightening level of commitment that a
scientist a good scientist must and does
bring to our work right this is you know
hardly anybody gets to win a Nobel Prize
hardly anybody gets to put down leave
work that has drawn on even 10 years
later heavily that's foundational to
their discipline 10 or 15 years later
very few their work is you know
indispensable for 25 years and a tiny
few fifty or a hundred years and even
the ones whose work the Newton's and
Einsteins and Darwin's
work gets revised it doesn't get thrown
out and replaced it gets elaborated
there are holes founded that must be
worked on nobody gets it completely
right you never have this final answer
and most people get to leave no mark
discernible mark at all it's like being
a poet right but they go to work every
day and they try to do things and this
is a noble thing and they also go to
work today with people down the hall who
hate them and there's rivals across the
country who are dying to kick their ass
and there's people in their Department
who got what they're doing there's
trouble at home they had their living
lives this is this is hard work and if
you if it's all a neat little just so
story you're missing all of this
opportunity now so what am I going to do
with what's been presented to me well
you got to wait for the answer for that
until I finish the book I don't want to
give away too much but you know my first
step it was funny I run into this idea
it's a very entrancing idea and I see
the reaction people have to it and I'm
talking to geneticists of every stripe
and you know I'm talking to genetics who
go do you know how many problems are
with this body of literature and they
tell me and now i know and i'll offer to
them you know you can you cannot talk
with them all day and i could get all
the people who believe deeply the
scientists who believe deeply in this in
together with the doubters and it will
be a very interesting conversation and i
realize this is so obviously immediate
as you say it it's so obvious you feel
stupid you never saw it i don't have to
adjudicate this debate Who am I to even
think of Judah caters to be and this
points out the arrogance of deciding
like the hubris of people who would say
well this is how it works the people
working on and don't even know how it
works yet but they're trying to figure
it out and this this search
simultaneously with the you know side by
side with the power of these ideas is
that not rich enough of course it's rich
enough it's just harder to write about
you got to find ways to make assets I
like this was a second realization
elected because it was resonant with the
theme of the these jeans right these
traits as I had to make a I had this
conflict I had to make an asset of the
conflict and that's a plotting problem
that's that's a structural problem
that's a writer's problem and instead of
just ignoring this conflict and the
friction that this idea faced I can
exploit that I can embed it in the
reader so what kind of experience do you
end up with if you read a book like this
if someone can write a book like this I
hope I can you are making real the
excitement of these ideas so that you
understand how exciting they are to the
people that pursue them you can make
real and compelling opposing ideas so
that watching them in opposition raises
the kind of tension and mixed feelings
that you know a baseball fan gets
watching a really good World Series
where you're not you know married to
either team you did like you don't know
who you want to win you can show the
reader what drives these people and how
much is at stake for all these
scientists and you can lead the reader
with a sense of not just Sciences
possibilities and beauty and its power
but also its its uncertainties in its
limits and if you can find the story of
a regular person a lay person to tell
who is also confronted these ideas and
takes it into her own life and ahead
because it changes the way she thinks
about the fragility that has riven her
family you have another layer that you
can offer the reader and what do you get
when you close a book like that
here I think of the novelist George
Simenon anybody read this is that these
are the wonderful jewels magrat pardon
my terrible French novels the French
detector Parisian detective what do
these right he wrote these things in
about 20 minutes or something but
there's 50 there 40 50 60 of these
they're all wonderful and he's a smart
man clever persistent as hell he's like
sort of like Columbo remember Colombo
some of you remember Colombo that it's a
wily detective only he it's much better
food because he's in Paris and McGrath
he always gets his man or his woman he
gets him every time but the entire how
was he gonna the whole time he's trying
to answer the same questions Stephen
Sumi is trying what makes people who
among my suspects is the one who seems
most likely to have done the things that
this murderer did he's trying to figure
out human nature and behavior and when
he gets to the end he doesn't Pat
himself on the back until himself he
knows everything these stories draw as
much meaning from McGrath's
mystification as from the arrest at the
end and when it's over we see that our
detective our hero he has solved one
mystery who done it but he remains
confounded by a deeper far more
important questions of human nature
cause chance and epistemology he's more
confused about the big picture than ever
and he knows well this is this is my
life I'm going to solve crimes are going
to be in a state of increasing wonder
that's a good way to close a book I
would propose a far richer state of mind
then the one in which we think we have
the answer to
how we behave it's not a state of
self-satisfied delusory completion but
you know a state of heightened
Inquisition of kind of ardent and humble
curiosity which i think is a far more
accurate representation of science and
really of how at our best we all think
in the head thanks I be very pleased to
take questions yes sir
study asking scientists what did they
read in our teacher and you might think
science that you know this mysteries
scientists as a practicing science that
was about the only one haha so show the
end of one this has to be trendy slices
thank you
but one of the questions might have as I
listened to you is that beyond the
mystery
the thrill of the chase we all
experience the science there are massage
and this question
neuroscience one of the assumptions that
our assumptions that lie and
the brain for our behavior or our
philosophy or ground luck and those
assumptions that brain
live Argentina
that's another
in your story your proposal to make to
represent science is kind of a mystery
yep yep beautiful how do you plan to
deal
so you're asking in a general sense or
you're asking am I going to go down the
mind brain rabbit hole yeah yeah oh no
no I haven't I heavenly thought that I
was dealing with that here but I think
implicitly I am is what you're saying
good um I am not in the context of this
book which has me at my limits enough
going to broach that question I'm afraid
they did that I'm not going to yes it is
it is yeah there's no doubt and it's
very confounding ya know it's funny I
mean this is oh my god my whole talks up
there that's not good okay um that's
been up there the whole time hasn't it
okay Oh what was in there I can't
remember it could have been a lot worse
I guess
uh now I completely forgot where he was
oh oh yes this gets it at what Janet
Malcolm calls the writers problem is
Janet Malcolm the people familiar with
hearse wonderful writer writes about
anything superb Lee but at the end of
her book about to Sylvia Plath she
describes going she wants to go visit
the guy who lived downstairs from Sylvia
Plath in the flat in London when Sylvia
Plath killed herself and left her two
children up with the milk and the notes
and the cookies um and she goes in this
guy's house he's very old now and she
has to like go sideways down the hall
because the the hallways are lined with
boxes full of stuff everywhere there's
stack stuff they just they bought pizza
they're simply trying to prepare the
people they have to clear out space in
the kitchen to make prepared dinner and
she's trying to think why she feels so
claustrophobic in this place and she
says because it's like the instantiation
of the writers problem you spend all
this time collecting all this stuff and
this this threatens to annihilate you
and that the rioters problem is not what
to put in the writers problem is what to
take out so that you have a clean a
story not a clean story but I mean will
a lean a coherent story and you know
that's I think that's that's been
helpful to me her making that point
because it really is it's what you throw
out kind of defines it yes Lee
genetic reasons for medical teams is
exciting you know practical implication
pardon me yes and when you find that
epigenetically seems to work these or
disease risk and also exciting because
we know that similar practical
applications are even change
environmental factors that kind of
decrease risk so when we can start with
a genetic basis for temperament or came
here or these danger that are not
pathological or call that in this person
what do you think the practical
implications are for fast I mean I can't
do anything like it these people write
emails to you undergo can be what are
they going to do that information I
don't you know if you I've had extended
correspondence with and they want them
curious they want and to their credit
they don't take it as I ok but explains
everything it's it's it's more data and
it helps not confirm something you're
just
they're thinking and they can use it
I thing you see here throughout this
entire literature is and it's easy to
drop and forget is the eat in the fridge
the environment was always huge you were
just that it's all good we can train
something change in all kinds of
situation so it's it's um I don't know
what you know its actual about things I
sure don't see it as you know God forbid
someone look at it as a new way to
select you know when it gonna work or
knock or something you see some kind of
logical jeans but I think it's a no I'm
not good at like how to do you ever feel
out of your work
no because I disagree small that listen
to me this increases all this I really
strong within them yeah yes sir since
you came promise to talk about
and I know this even
bro and I assume that's not a stick if
you have made a decision in this talk it
is gone are you in the book in the book
you're going to look you know I mean
that's another rabbit wall yeah before
it's a PI PO box unless it's one of us
look at us because and because the point
that you're making about Norma's history
assignment process is so by so many and
bound that I worry
genetics which is
working now RMS that was hold so much
promise and so many right now but it's
like three on the scale up woman well I
mean I won't get into theirs it can be
careful time in a limited sense i'll
talk about epigenetics in the sense of
knotted not in the heritable epigenetic
changes sense right I'll be there
briefly to acknowledge its existence in
a simulation in this one is work but
it's one of those things I happened
inside well you know that's for someone
else to work out there is some gene
expression stuff in
I have known article called social life
of jeans
it is about gene expression changes in
gene expression response activity in
response to Jesus second so that
definitely
neither one but that was okay I've heard
about a lot of people excited about it
yeah I just didn't get to it yes sir
here's that we have added I sent my life
is full of work for it around understood
yeah student support teams of workers
and hobbies differently all kind of
interesting and also it resonated it
kind of fun was consistent with their
experience yes oh you're the luck from
nutrition and when you're writing about
Christie SMS as the mystery are you
going to look at it from the perspective
of people who try to use actually kind
of knowledge and concrete situations
with your win children Kevin final error
that goes into the of the work with that
I'll just say that doesn't play a big
role in my approach to this story that
which is not to say that's not worth
exploring yeah it does and I think this
is part of the attraction of this
hypothesis especially as in comparison
to the psychiatric risk gene view is
that it it seems to you know it offers
to to reconcile science with with common
experience and vernacular knowledge if
you will vernacular language God he's a
mercurial son-of-a-bitch things are
either greater they're awful nothing
affects that guy it just rolls huh I
mean these are these are these are types
that we've recognized for agents and and
this this is consistent with that which
doesn't make it all right I mean I think
from a temperamental point of view you
throw the jeans out here and most of
this is close to an arguable some might
offer well if it's that an arguable it
doesn't mean anything but it offers to
reconcile things that way it with
genetic point of view and this is why it
resonates with a lot of people in
education and I think well this sort of
answer is that what do you do with this
to the practical aspects one is it can
just simply give you a little more
patience with someone a kid who is you
know like he's either the best kid in
class he's you know a teacher he likes
the subject he lights you can't stop
this kid he's great a teacher who done
connect us you know classes run poorly
he bails he flunks algebra to my sunday
this and this and it gives you patience
or you know but I it helped me like my
daughter's you know throwing a meltdown
she's four years old and the world is
ending because the seam in the back of
her sock does not line up with the seam
in her tights and we can't get to school
until we fix this problem right but this
is the same girl who when she shines
it's like for son right and so these
maybe this is you know there you can
delude yourself about these things but
in education I think it is value because
it you know we can realize okay there's
something here to work with I got to
figure it out yes sir
ya know it is and it's like all of the
media world you know in upheaval right
now because of you know all the changes
and you can get stuff you know the
atomization of the ecosystem by the
internet and people write read articles
now instead of publications and blah
blah blah and the different pay scale it
sits in huge disruption I actually think
that you know Carl and I we like been on
panels talking about this this gets
talked about a lot among the science
writing community but I really believe
that there is more good science writing
it around now than there ever has been
it's it is because it's not all in
newspapers right i mean they're almost
no newspaper science sections and how
many were there 15 years ago there was
dozens every regional paper had a saitek
thing and now there's like three The
Times and who else is left hardly
anybody but there's all these I mean the
science blog affair blogosphere is a
rich place so Carl rights is one of the
best science writers in the world he
writes for The Times he also writes a
blog at National Geographic that he
started himself when was it you were
like a early bird 2004-5 so yeah right
ten years ago right then its own little
site obscure and then it moved to
science blogs and then it moved to
discover now it's at National Geographic
and he's got partners you know other
bloggers that are blocked putting out
great stuff there as kid ed young who is
unbelievable he's on fire it's not a kid
anymore but I can call them that and
Virginia Hughes who is also there's it's
just I mean there's way more really good
science writing being produced every
week than I can even start to read but
it's harder to find it yeah anyone else
yes ma'am
Oh
I have first
so the first thing the
nation that maybe observe
who to change the environment changed at
Harbor citty base to change the proposed
ingenuity
no I mean carnage seems to be going by
University well in schools I mean this
is the big challenge in school is to
have a environment that is stimulating
to every child at but order manageable
right I mean this is hard enough if you
have two kids right you're raising them
at home and you got 20 in a room this is
a really hard problem great teachers are
still the key I recently spent a year in
London and I live in my paper Vermont
where the class size in elementary
schools about 15 and those they don't
how much trouble don't want to get a
school board it couldn't get any worse
actually um but you know a lot of the
classrooms are not orderly there some of
them are you know my girls teacher right
now is a wonderful teacher but we moved
to London the class sizes were 25 every
other factor that is blamed for tough
education here the the social economic
level of the students the diversity of
the students was x 18 at this school
they went to in London and this place
ran like a Swiss watch and everybody was
happy it was orderly I didn't and I
don't know what to quite make of that
that was a very diverse student body 350
families 41st languages spoken in homes
those students right they were from all
over a planet and an orderly classroom
where everyone knew what to expect and
within maybe a narrower range close
attention to what each kid needed to do
that it seemed to me when we went just
there a year but it I was impressed with
the school which gets me I don't know
where I don't you know it's a hard
problem yes Lisa
potentially cause conversion so for
example cancer cells they can they can
actually convert stats let's say hormone
receptor status very technical you know
texted think that if you apply
chemotherapy certain breast cancer cells
will actually convert status from
hormone receptor positive to negative
protein positive to negative by the
actual application of external that an
intended effect well their worries now
to see that if some of these cells
actually do convert that has
implications for long-term prognosis
because they're showing greater
responsiveness directly yeah your visual
assessment so I'm interested if you see
any corollary to could there be
environmental stimulus that would cause
an orchid to come a dandelion or
deadline to become how big a magnitude
let's say if someone gets I've got you
know a certain medical diagnosis or
something very traumatic in their life
does that actually put that pause them
to convert some people say well it just
brings out men
what was already there when I put you to
good just do that one could you actually
convert status from I don't know I mean
people do become more or less reactive
at least behaviorally I mean this is
part of what we do when we grow up right
we can't you know my daughter doesn't
freak out about her socks as often now
she's not right and sensitivity doesn't
mean necessarily mean you have a visible
you're visible behavioral response is
more robust particularly if you you have
other you know help and gifts or whatnot
in in refashioning your behavior so that
you learn to control yourself in certain
situations or redirect your behavior and
those I that's a tough one nice i don't
know i I'm gonna I'm gonna punch
Oh